All right so today
We're going to try something I've been wanting to do for years
a knife fight
where we actually dip the knives in red paint so that way you can know when you get a hit on somebody because when you're
Using rubber knives and swords it's all guesswork really as to like, how you hit somebody, where you hit them. It's like
Oh, I vaguely remember getting hit over here
hey Nick, Nick!
Sup?
We need help outside
Why what are you shooting? We're shooting a paint fight
A paint fight? yeah.
Dude I'm going to ruin another pair of clothes if we do that
No, you won't!
Every single time, I ruin my clothes when we shoot with paint.
They're not even using that much paint.
Let's go!
Just the blade. You only want the edge
You know? Just saying, you don't want slappers.
So that way when you're slapped you'll be able to see versus sliced.
You gotta wet your knife.
Peter, Peter! Welcome in. You already lost!
Nick's lost like five pairs of pants.
Did you get red on you?
Yeah, he's already died.
It's okay. The shirt was $5.
Somebody with a knife is incredibly hard to deal with,
Because you're going to get cut even if you're a really good fighter
And you know how to handle it
It's very hard to survive a knife fight without getting touched. So we should put that to the test.
You know what would make great content for the Corridor channel?
This knife fight. What? Yeah! Dude, you're crazy.
Did you not see the poll that people posted?
I saw the poll, but sometimes people don't know what they want until you give it to them.
You know what I'm sayin?
I know exactly what I want, and that's for you to get cut
There's no fantasy here. This is real life.
Three, two, one, fight.
Aw man, this is so creepy.
*dramatic music*
Alright, we got a slice here on the back of the shoulder
Niko, you got sliced in the arm for sure.
I got hit in the-
Ohhh and in the back!
A cut like that you'd survive and keep swinging so I would say this fight is far from over.
Guys, second round about to begin.
Okay, a monarch butterfly keeps flitting around here.
Oh boy. All right.
Oh! OHHHH!
Sliced 'im right across the chest.
*breathless laughing*
Ooh, that's a gnarly one.
Ya done cut my nips!
Ohhh, that's a solid slice, actually.
That's a solid slice.
Oh, we're doing left hands now?
It's the final round,  fight!
*everyone talking* I got- Nico just- an arm slice- a slight gash
Dude, my abs hurt so bad.
Your ribs would stop it from probably getting in.
You would have just slashed my ribs
The internet's down again.
Peter!
This happens every six to eight weeks. The internet will just go down for a half a day or an entire day
it's impossible to get anything done when you're a company that makes videos for the internet
But we have to deliver this cut-
- to a brand for a brand integration that we're doing in the in the next video
and we can't get it over to them so Chris is going to have to take off go somewhere that does have internet and then
I'm trying to get this production going for this other thing we're doing.
Yes, I can look at stuff on my phone
But it's not nearly the same thing trying to check 50 emails on your phone and coordinate those with the rest of a company
From a screen that's this big?
We're going to change up the colors now that we are moving into a new stage
that way we can differentiate the cuts
We're going to go to bog green, it'll show pretty well on the white.
Keep it clean, gentlemen.
oh- oh- Ohh.
You cut me in the arm.
Wait wait, I think that I think it's a flick.
It felt like a slap.
Instant replay.
Look at my paint. It looks like it might have been a flick.
Maybe got a nick. Ooh yeah, that's a slapper.
You got me with a slapper.
oh- Oh!
ohhh!
*censor bleep*
*laughing*
Gotcha!
Sorry.
Yeah!
well I think I got you I got you with a trick
I swung open and you were like woah, and then I came back and it's just like pshheww
Aaah! Aaah! Aaaaaah!
It felt kind of like a slice.
It's more of, it's like a backhanded slap.
Oh, you got it. That's a good old-fashioned slice. You nicked my shirt too.
Alright, you guys do the fight left-handed.
Here we go, ding ding ding. So there's a new fighting style I'm gonna introduce.
Ooohhhhhh-ahahah!
Yes, the broken blade. Yes. I got you with like six, up to six cuts.
Sliced, my elbow's hanging loose right there.
It's at the end, I'm just slapping you with a broken blade.
So check this out. You know how there are the geotags on snapchat?
look at this one. Look at this little geotag, look at that!
It knows that's pretty cool wait for it
Whoa that's crazy got our own geo tag now. Did you guys in bridge as a jeweler somehow? How did that? I don't know
We might know as per does somebody have to hurt like every other area assad. Did you do this nope?
How big's the Geotech what I mean?
How big is like could you go slightly can we go to chef you know look luckiness escorted it
I don't know. Let's go see yes
You're in corridor digital territory now boys
It's on!
Yeah, we will arm cut through that's smack right there whoo
All right, I guess you lost your right hand round two
to fight oh
I got you pretty clean there. You should give me away wow hit, but you didn't make it out without getting nicked
Semi clean guys. Semi clean.
oh
Skittish
You went in like this
Let's do a full on every man for himself. Street brawl!
State brawl! This is to revenge my grandfather. And my son. And my daughter.
What?
Oh you just bumped me. You didn't even count.
You wanna gang- you wanna gang up? Yeah.
*dramatic music*
I need more paint.
Yeah, a deadly downwards swans. No. I'm just gonna go crazy on this one. May the best fighter win. Downward swan.
laughs I got your in that oh ah
ah
I'm gonna paint my name on your tombstone. I can count a lot I
Got them with it with a good old lineage strike there yeah classic lineage strike
Sam's autopsy if you can see chest hits, were a very popular way to go with me
I got this obviously. It's true lineage strike. Oh your left shoulder, man
This is probably the most critical strike with beams like yeah, there's a little here, but this kind of looks like oh there
That's a good strike. Oh, man. Yeah one again. Lean strikes. That was me
I'm proud of that so yeah once again the right arm. You want to put all your armor on the right arm
Probably when you go on eve. I have one on my nose too. Yeah
Yeah, I got tyrians the linnaeus right as I clean - you're a really bad place to get cut right
Yeah, this is when I pitted you. Yeah, oh
Look at the cleanliness this eileen throw in this one right here to clean strikes. Well, we've learned so far
Is that once you commit any night wise just run it through you're going to get slashed either way so all you can really do
To make sure that your slash is a better slash yeah
Hey, everybody last year
We did something really fun
And that was the gif contest we asked people to make a gif
Gif not jif out of any of the favorite scenes from a Sam Niko video, Corridor video
It could really be anything as long as it was corridor related today marks the announcement of the second annual gif
Contest pick up the best gifable moments and submit them for a chance to win something really cool such as a monopod
Some sweet limit edition quarter digital merch or a fidget spinner psych all the losers get fidget spinners. Don't worry
That's right
So go to anybody you want make a gif however you'd like stylize however you want and send an email to us
gifs@corridordigital.com Submit your gif by Wednesday evening
End of the day Wednesday evening details are in the description below also
It's in case you want there's a little spider a little spider hanging from the Chuck and Mike. Where's Wren?
What advice it's kind of pitch for like a feature film?
He's hoping some more like buys and fund the movie
So it kind of ends in a bit of a cliffhanger, but the premise is amazing firebase is
a film that takes place in 1970 Vietnam so during the Vietnam War and
there's all this crazy stuff happening like
Tanks are getting blown up into the sky people are just exploding and like really really brutal stuff and the way they
slowly reveal all of that is actually a
Direction I didn't anticipate it started going like okay is alien or a robot, but then you're like wait
What is it and then it ends in a cliffhanger is like the guys about the I will almost boy lays. It's great